let's talk about the confession booth
that we hear here which we also had a
Norway chest so if the players during
the game has me they get off their
chests they want to talk about the game
what's going on it's really exciting for
the viewer air so all these players have
the option to use the confession booth
and Grand Master have 100 Ramirez is
gonna test it out for us
all right well well we are here and the
floor of the playing hall the players
are right over there and a cool new
feature of the 2015 Sinquefield Cup is
as in Norway the players have the option
of using in a confessional booth for
them to just say what they're thinking
to say I'll doubt their thoughts and
maybe even collect themselves a little
bit when we can show you everything they
say so let's check it out that come
so this area is soundproof and the
players can come here and say their
thoughts I can pretend to beat the pile
of em be like oh you know g5 I was just
bluffing or something and hopefully the
players you said often so we know what
they're thinking and well that's a
confessional booth back to you Jen and
yeah sir wow I hope nobody makes me go
in the castle I might be in it for way
too long
you know sometimes you know you make a
move and you're proud of the move you
made and then you get up from the board
and go oh I go into the confession booth
just a scream like I did it wrong it is
soundproof but if you scream louder off
somebody might right there
Oh beautiful to hear you do you still
make a sound well we look forward to
hearing from some players and the
confession booth